Yeah, I guess, uh, going off of that, I want to ask, like, you know,
obviously you draw, God knows how many hours per day, right? Like,
I'm sure you've run into like, you know, injuries and like risk problems. Like,
is there like certain stuff that you do to like,
make sure you don't hurt yourself?
Where are you happy? They have to do some stretch.
I have a message board or to my, for my hands to stretch like that or.
Yeah, like those like risk odds that I see some animators wearing. No, not me.
Uh, but uh, yeah, if we, um, one, two hours, I have to do some stretch or
sitting and you have also have a good seat. Good.
Do you have a good gamer chair at home?
I remember Joe Brown. Betty. Yeah. But in fact, if I'm working on tablet so,
and furniture, unfortunately I cannot be like that.
[inaudible].
Don't forget the microphone by the way. Sorry. Um, I guess it's the same,
same kind of precautions. A lot of let's say like,
like professional gamers and e-sports athletes have to go through because you
doing a lot of movements on your wrist, carpal tunnel, right?
Yeah. Yeah. So sometimes I have been here, so,
uh, so yeah, so, uh, uh, in fact animators have to do sport or so because yeah,
so I did something, I, um,
went to Gore gym with my friend Maggie and to do some exercise
because a yes, you lose, you lose muscles. Yeah. Yeah.
I do feel doing YouTube as well. Cause I'm sat at my desk all day. I got,
gotta do something.
Which is a coroner. So now you, yeah, you don't, you don't leave much.
You don't move much. Yes.
To, to the desk, to the fridge. Right.
[inaudible] like a teenager was sitting at your desk,
playing video games all day and all night or whatever you never think about. Oh,
what are the ergonomics right now? You know? You never,
you never think about that part of my body, my injuries. Exactly.
I did feel bad. Cause when I, I used to play games,
like she's gonna pretty much from after school till I went to bed and I never
had any problems and my other friend would play like two hours a night.
If he was lucky and he got carpal tunnel. Oh Jesus. And I was like, you're weak,
real gamers. You ain't a pro gamer.
We're going to look at those weak wrists. Get out of here.
Those on gamer risks, get some real thumbs. I was just like, boy, I'm like,
why am I risk not giving it this? Man's uh,
giving it like Chad risks. Maybe I came up with a wound
[inaudible] natural selection, like shows you in the wrong way. You know,
my kid is going to have like jacked risks, like natural selection,
like, Oh my God.
So most of when you are young, you can stay more longer just at your heart.
But when you get older,
you have no family kids and you can't afford to just stay out day, go back to,
to home. Yeah.
No, no. One of your simplest controls so fast, they need to.
It was that. And he was trained to so right.
And there was this pressure and these, uh,
those deadlines make them more, uh, faster and faster,
but in good, you have the quality. Yeah.
But sometimes when you have a much experience,
you have to get faster in some time you have to sacrifice the quality. Yeah.
And I.
And I suppose, are those, the scenes that kind of always get MeMed on,
on Twitter and social media and stuff. Yeah.
And there's also, you have just seen, Oh wow.
A day was, uh, a bit a mess. Uh, some because of the communication,
wasn't good. Or with the production, uh,
the animator didn't have time to do it or it was Jenny
Metta. Couldn't do it. Okay. We've have nobody. Okay. We'll give it to China,
Korea to deviate and, and China CRA, Oh, we don't have time.
We have to speed it, right? Yes.
Seven deadly sins depends also,
which is will to eat because sometimes you have a gloss name.
So for example, you have stirred, you have a, we do
[inaudible] bet. Oh, we don't have much time. We have to do, uh, we have,
we do just a 10 episode and the two will be done by defense to do so.
We asked to study a, B and C to do, uh, each one episode.
And if a BNC don't have the good stuff, it looks bad.
You have some accident. And also more than the studio,
you should more look at this tough to start that the studio is like a share
and just give them a good,
a good environment to,
for a good working place for the animators and a good assistant productions,
but, or the skills and all the,
the staff will be art or in freelance. So it's a study of who,
uh, okay.
If you can do this project and we can give you a good working walking.
Yeah.
Always wondered. Cause you know, there's,
there's always like the meme in our community where if,
if an episode is animated well, versus an episode that's animated bad.
We always talk about like, Oh, it's the budget. You know, they're not,
they're not given enough budget, but like how, like how, how true is that?
How is that actually reflected or like, is it, do they have,
is it all about the staff that they can hire? And the staff, that's all.
It's tough. A lot of things. In fact, you have also the budget,
but for example, you have an MPS that you have a lot of action,
lots of movements. Uh, actually one episode is two,
350 cuts. But for some,
a lot of heavy episode, a lot of action,
Epic episode can have a 500 cuts. Right?
So for this episode it will be or expensive,
more expensive pocket cut. But so for the next episode,
you have to adjust to this, right.
So if.
You had to claim X on X episode seven,
so maybe episode eight will be more cool. Right.
And you talked about some animators being more experienced and more skilled and
like have, have making a name for themselves. Can they, um,
can they negotiate a higher price per cuts? Yeah.
Yeah. Uh, actuary. So, uh,
so their rate of the Duquette is, uh, when you,
when you have the offer and so you said you, the rate of the cut is this.
So most of the series is a 4,500 yen.
So I don't know, $5, roughly five pounds for one cup, one cut,
one cut can take you like a one hour, one day,
two days.
Oh gosh. $5 for two days.
Someday. Amy, it can take you a one weekend. Okay.
I know a great website called Fiverr.
Um, so like that's a huge meal you can ask, excuse me. Um, you, you, you, you.
[Inaudible] smile.
You have to negotiate for this guy. Is it a heavy cat?
Can you put it twice,
twice a price or three times the price, please. You have to negotiate.
And sometimes if you are very, very famous, like, uh,
we call this a super animator, like a one man army,
right? You say, my rate is this okay.
They want to, they want to, because you just go.
Well, if you have very famous mate,
I Coreen like a veteran and sure they have the name value or because
in the show, people want to look it. Right.
So that's kind of how like a voice was like, YouTube is too right.
It's just like,
if you're a famous YouTuber that has so much years of experience,
then you can just be like, yeah. You know, honestly,
if you've made a name for yourself, you deserve a higher.
We can set that. It's a bit like a soccer teams, uh, when you're, Oh,
I want to want to run. Ardo messy.
Right? Yeah. Is that why, whenever you see like the climax of a big scene,
especially in like some shown anatomy or like some big,
you always see the same names animating.
Oh, same name as a yes. All the line or some new ones,
because some, you cannot relate or only have some few names.
So you have to find new talent, right? Yeah.